[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und christian sievers
guten abend in allen tja so ist das wenn
der kandidat auf die trifft die es jetzt
in der hand haben wie es mit ihm
weitergeht
bei einer bundestagswahl bei der es auf
jede stimme ankommt und zwar im wahrsten
sinn des wortes denn so eng sieht das
rennen aktuell ja aus das waren 90
minuten gerade live im zdf mit einem der
in den umfragen abgestürzt ist der jetzt
alles geben muss um seine chance wahren
zu können aufs kanzleramt klartext armin
laschet
laschet erster schlagabtausch eben nicht
mit der konkurrenz sondern direkt mit
wählerinnen und wählern vor einem
millionen-publikum wir analysieren das
jetzt und gucken auch noch einmal auf
die wichtigsten momente mit dem
parteienforscher professor karl rudolf
korte schindler berlin guten haben was
war dann vielleicht für den anfang das
überraschendste jetzt für sie ja das ist
kein nur frage und antwort war sondern
dass wir ein schlagabtausch erlebt haben
der dialogischen nachgefragt er nach
geburt von sich aus das fand ich
überraschend und vielleicht auch noch
dass er diese mittlere unentschiedenheit
die immer vorgeworfen wird verlassen hat
er war viel präziser als sonst hätten
wir gleich noch im detail vielen dank
für den moment und wir gucken jetzt mal
auf die speziellen momente zurück
eineinhalb stunden klartext in drei
minuten zusammengefasst von mathis
feldhoff ist
es die chance zur trendwende oder doch
nur die bestätigung schlechter umfragen
für armin laschet geht es um alles und
er stellt sich 70 gästen und zwei
moderatoren zu vier themen
den klimawandel erlebt der kandidat
hautnah im eigenen hinterhof das
sommerhochwasser hat zu toten so
weggeschwemmte ortschaften und zu
milliarden schäden geführt und laschet
das image des verlierers verpasst heute
verteidigt er die schnelle hilfe
besonders die finanzielle ich war
mehrmals dort bei den menschen und das
erste war die soforthilfe die natürlich
wichtig war weil viele alles verloren
hat die hatten ja nicht mal mehr eine ec
karte oder irgendwas dass das geld
ausgezahlt wird ich habe mir damals das
formular zeige lassen vom amt wie sieht
das aus ich will dass das unbürokratisch
ist da steht drauf name kontonummer
eventuell sogar barauszahlung ich
versichere dass ich wirklich ein
flurschaden hat fertig doch
klimapolitisch hat sich die union
zurückgehalten im wahlprogramm
wohlklingende worte konkrete zahlen zur
co2 steuer zum ende des
verbrennungsmotors sucht man vergebens
wir haben das ziel dass 1,5 grad ziel zu
erreichen das ist die absicht sie können
das nur nicht im jahre
2021 exakt für das jahr
229 beantworten wir brauchen jetzt die
dynamik wir brauchen die wissenschaft
wir brauchen die forscher wir brauchen
die entwicklung der speichertechnologien
klartext bekommt der wähler vom
kandidaten zum thema afd amila stellt
wiederholt seine aussagen ohne wenn und
aber und bekommt dafür gegenwind
wir werden mit der afd nicht reden nicht
kooperieren nicht koalieren gar nichts
ich tue alles dass die aus den
parlamenten verschwinden eine
rechtsradikale partei die gegen andere
menschen hetzt hat in deutschen
parlamenten nichts verloren haben also
kein rechtsradikaler ich finde trotzdem
dass sie mit dieser aussage
spalten denn jede partei jede partei im
deutschen parlament hat eine
daseinsberechtigung und sollte auch
angehört werden
das ende der steinkohle das ende der
braunkohle laschet nimmt für sich in
anspruch strukturwandel begriffen zu
haben als wahlkämpfer verspricht er
jetzt die zukunft zu erobern ein besuch
in der tesla fabrik in brandenburg soll
dieses image und da mal arbeiten doch
der wähler im studio will allerdings
wissen wie sich der mindestlohn für zwei
millionen beschäftigte entwickelt
laschet will nicht dass sich die politik
einmischt wenn wir beginnen löhne
auszuhandeln im deutschen bundestag wird
es am ende die gewerkschaften schwächen
und das ist keine gute lösung
im kampf gegen korona wirkt laschet oft
wie der luftikus ohne klare linie ein
image auch nicht von fakten gedeckt das
wie pech an ihm klebt auch der ständige
zweikampf mit söder um den preis des
besseren corona bekämpfer verliert er
zumindest in den umfragen
wir haben viele grundrechtseingriffe den
menschen zugemutet und ich war immer
einer der roller manche hat eröffnet
viel zu schnell der gesagt hat wenn die
zahlen sinken müssen wir eingriffe auch
wieder zurücknehmen laschet steht mit
dem rücken zur wand aber als rheinische
frohnatur will er sich nicht von
schlechten umfragen verrückt machen
lassen
wir merken es wird knapp die wähler
werden das entscheiden und ich empfehle
uns einfach diese 17 tage jetzt
abzuwarten
armin laschet stellt sich zur wahl und
den fragen der wähler noch hat der 17
tage zeit
17 tage noch professor karl rudolf korte
ist noch bei uns welche strategie konnte
man denn da jetzt heute abend rauslesen
für armin laschet in den kommenden 17
tagen er ist konfrontiert mit bestimmten
projektionen mit mit images mit bildern
gegen die anderen dazu gehört zum
beispiel dass er uneindeutig ist das
eher unklar ist da hat er versucht eben
viel präziser zu sein dass er zu real
ist also vielleicht zu wenig ernst er
hat heute abend auf keinen fall jeden
nur recht gegeben und war nur der
kümmerer der sympathisch rumba rüberkam
sondern er hat offenen widerspruch
artikuliert auch hier hat er versucht
dagegen zu steuern und es wird ihm ja
oft vorgeworfen dass er vielleicht krise
nicht kann dass er nicht stressresistent
ist und man die sendung an sich zeigt
dass er doch mit vielen themen offenbar
umgehen kann in vielen auch sonst sehr
kritischen porträts über ihnen steht zu
lesen laschet kann gut immer wenn es
direkt mit menschen wenn es auf den
direkten umgang mit menschen ankommt war
das heute abend etwas was ihm geholfen
hat in der sendung ja denn die meisten
haben ja nur medien vermittelte
eindrücke vom politiker hier kommt mal
etwas für diese 70 die im studio waren
rüber und das wir transportiert für uns
was für wahlentscheidung extrem wichtig
ist ist die sache argumentation danach
kommen andere punkte wie
führungsverhalten glaubwürdigkeit und
vor allen dingen auch sympathie das
wichtigste ist die sachkompetenz und
damit kann man brillieren in seiner
sendung oder man geht ein geradezu
insofern können sich zuschauer ein
eigenes bild machen und damit wird
wichtig unterstrichen dass politik
komplex eben ist und das ist das
entscheidende das einzusehen nicht
einfach man kann nicht nur ja nein sagen
sondern das ist sehr sehr differenziert
dieser eindruck setzt sich immer wenn
man politikern begegnet war in der
sendung gemerkt dass gegen wirklich um
viel es kamen sehr viele themen viele
auch ganz persönliche anliegen
schicksale es war so ein parforce-ritt
durch all das was deutschland im moment
bewegt dabei reden wir noch kurz über
vielleicht über ein thema denn es ist ja
für armin laschet grundsätzlich diese
herausforderung wie umgehen mit kritik
an der vergangenheit an der regierung
der vergangenheit ohne die kanzlerin die
16 jahre an der macht war also sehr zu
kritisieren karl rudolf korte beim thema
atomausstieg kohleausstieg gab es dann
eine interessante situation ja der hat
er doch andere termine geradezu genannt
das vielleicht eher vorzuziehen nicht
nur seinen weg geschildert und auch
zugegeben dass er wenn er die
reihenfolge hätte beeinflussen können
anders als die kanzlerin erst den
kohleausstieg gewählt hätte und dann
erst den atomausstieg und insofern ist
das eine aussage die wir bisher in
dieser form nicht kannten die blitz
analyse von professor karl rudolf korte
herzlichen dank dafür
und jede diskussionsrunde jetzt jetzt im
moment ist auch deshalb so wichtig und
entscheidend weil immer mehr wählerinnen
und wähler schon vor dem wahltag wählen
und sobald sie gewählt haben dann
natürlich für den wahlkampf nicht mehr
zu erreichen sind 29 prozent briefwahl
so war das vor vier jahren dieses mal
erwarten alle noch mal deutlich mehr
vielleicht doppelt so viel auf jeden
fall eine rekord wahl per post und je
wichtiger die briefwahl ist desto lauter
werden die die warnen sie sei nicht
sicher david gepaart ist dem
nachgegangen in 17 tagen ist wahltag
doch eigentlich wird schon jetzt jeden
tag gewählt so viel briefwahl anteil wie
noch nie wird erwartet und die parteien
werben dafür offensiv alle bis auf eine
stecken selber rein fordert die afd denn
ein briefkasten sei keine war geboren
wir sagen ganz klar dass oben weil sie
sichere wahl ist das sind fordern die
mellon bürger auf ihre geheime stimme im
wahllokal abzugeben auf den marktplätzen
werden auf die vertreter mitunter
deutlicher verbreiten des information
über einen angeblich drohenden
wahlbetrug etwa bei der auszählung der
briefwahl sind nicht
einfach gehen beruf zu passen dass wir
nicht beschissen im gegenteil in
deutschland nicht von uns wird das ist
nämlich 41 wieder werden in barum kann
unter umständen
nicht die rechte bahn endlich verwandelt
weil eure kreuzer einfach worauf
falschen aufgelegte behauptungen mit dem
ziel die briefwahl zu diskreditieren
der bundeswahlleiter weist die vorwürfe
entschieden zurück die briefwahl ist
genauso sicher wie die ohne wahl lassen
sie sich nicht nicht verunsichern unser
wahlsystem ist seit der gründung der
bundesrepublik deutschland ein sehr
sicheres die lüge von der angeblich
gestohlenen wahl von donald trump
verbreitet damals wie heute von
fdp-vertretern dankbar aufgegriffen
beiden als zwei betrüger
das wird ja immer noch diskutiert es
wird auch noch nach gezählt schon kurz
nach der us-wahl kapern fdp-vertreter
dass trump narrativ und verbreiten
verschwörungs erzählungen
ist ein schwindel die aus völlig anderen
grünen
verursacht wird weil sie briefwahl
durchführen will um den größten
wahlbetrug dieses landes im nächsten
jahr neu zu hören und news rund um wein
und die pandemie alltagsgeschäft für den
daten analysten josef holnburger
die relative die sich jetzt das
vermeintlich manipulierten bundestags
weiteren die kommen vor allem aus unter
störungs ideologischen und auch
rechtsextremen milieu
allein dieses video hat fast 400.000
klicks
alle wenig ist eine der
reichweitenstärksten deutschsprachigen
verschwörungs ideologen der hat
vermeintlich nach der sachsen anhalts
wahl entdeckt wo manipuliert worden wäre
und waren auch ganz eindeutig vor der
nächsten bundestagswahl zana d zulueta
hat weltweit über 25 jahre wahlen
beobachtet für die osze auch in
deutschland sie sieht einen
erschreckenden trend
leider ist der ruf vom angeblichen
wahlbetrug zu einer politischen taktik
geworden eine abscheuliche die
ansteckung scheint deutschland erreicht
zu haben dabei ist der deutsche prozess
einer der transparentesten die ich je
gesehen habe
ein prozess der dieses jahr ganz neu
herausgefordert werden könnte durch
einen historischen briefwahl anteil mit
vermutlich mehr als 50 prozent und durch
kräfte die zweifel schüren am
demokratischen verfahren
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat vor ein
paar jahren sehr schön den zielkonflikt
beschrieben zwischen den grundsätzen
einer freien demokratischen wahl geheim
soll sie sein dass bietet am nächsten
natürlich die wahlkabine im wahllokal
aber allgemein soll sie eben auch sein
für alle zugänglich auch für die die nur
zu hause ihr kreuz machen wollen oder
können
so heinz hat jetzt einen ersten
nachrichtenüberblick für uns zuerst zu
den corona zahlen zur krone situation
die sieben tage in tendenz ist wieder
leicht gestiegen auf
83,5 innerhalb eines tages haben sich
15.000 431 menschen mit dem virus
infiziert
606 menschen kamen neu mit symptomen ins
krankenhaus damit steigt die sogenannte
hospitalisierung ist er rate auf 189
fälle pro 100.000 einwohner den höchsten
stand gab es an weihnachten mit
15,75
von alarmierenden folgen der pandemie
für die gesundheit der kinder und
jugendlichen spricht die krankenkasse
dak-gesundheit nach der analyse
anonymisierter krankenhausdaten so sein
2020 die krankenhausbehandlungen von
mädchen und jungen wegen übergewicht um
60 prozent im vergleich zum vorjahr
gestiegen bei essstörungen wie bulimie
und magersucht waren es demnach fast
zehn prozent mehr
razzien heute im bundesfinanz sowie im
bundesjustizministerium die
staatsanwaltschaft osnabrück ermittelt
gegen die geldwäsche zentralstelle des
zolls der sogenannten fau wird
vorgeworfen hinweise von banken zur
geldwäsche nicht an polizei und justiz
weitergeleitet zu haben bei der
durchsuchung der ministerien ging es um
die kommunikation mit der fau und auch
um die frage inwieweit
verantwortliche in den ministerien in
entscheidungen der geldwäsche stelle mit
eingebunden waren
bundesaußenminister maas hat die
deutsche botschaft in libyen eröffnet
vor sieben jahren waren alle deutschen
diplomaten aus dem nordafrikanischen
land abgezogen worden wegen des dort
herrschenden bürgerkrieges bei der
wiedereröffnung in der hauptstadt
tripolis erklärte maas die fortschritte
des landes seien beeindruckend
deutschland wolle den libyerinnen und
libyen beim aufbau einer besseren
zukunft helfen
die neue taliban regierung in
afghanistan schlägt einen harten kurs
gegen meinungsfreiheit und frauenrechte
proteste seien bis auf weiteres verboten
niemand solle es wagen welche zu
organisieren hieß es aus dem neuen
innenministerium in den letzten tagen
gab es noch proteste gegen die taliban
regierung auch von frauen weil keine
einzige frau in der regierung vertreten
ist und weil frauen zunehmend freiheiten
und rechte genommen werden etwa bei
bildung und arbeit und oder der ausübung
von sport
ja für viele bleibt da nur ein ausweg
sie versuchen ihr land zu verlassen seit
heute ist afghanistan wieder mit der
welt verbunden auf dem luftweg zehn tage
nach dem abzug der us-truppen ist wieder
ein ziviler evakuierungs flug gestartet
in kabul airport qatar airways mit ziel
doha der hauptstadt von katar dessen
regierung will den flughafen generell
für internationale flüge wieder öffnen
heute waren rund 200 menschen an bord
darunter auch us bürger zehntausende
vielleicht noch mehr warten auf so eine
chance im nachbarland iran das mit
afghanistan eine
936 kilometer lange bergige grenze hat
leben bereits rund drei millionen
afghanen die meisten illegal und das
schon vor der machtübernahme der taliban
jetzt kommen immer mehr jörg brase ist
dort in ihrer heimat war es dann am
sabbat ein kinostar in ihren filmen
spielte sie starke frauen die sich gegen
traditionen und zwänge auflehnen sie
ließ ihre ehe scheiden im film wie im
echten leben das mochten ihre
konservativen eltern nicht und die neuen
herrscher in afghanistan die taliban
recht nicht sie floh nun sitzt sie hier
im nachbarland iran in sicherheit zwar
doch sie weiß nicht wie es weitergehen
soll weiß ich habe angst zurück zu gehen
aber hier bleiben geht auch nicht mein
visum läuft bald aus und wird
wahrscheinlich nicht verlängert dann
wäre ich ein illegaler afghanischer
flüchtling das mache ich nicht dann
versuche ich lieber irgendwie von dir
wegzukommen
in iran ist sie eine von mittlerweile
über drei millionen afghanen viele ohne
legales visum ein slum im südosten der
hauptstadt teheran die meisten hier
kommen aus afghanistan
staatliche hilfe bekommen sie nicht
müssen sogar die abschiebung fürchten
ihr seht wie wir leben wir hatten kein
wasser und keinen strom das zapfen wir
alles illegal irgendwo ab und egal wohin
wir gehen werden wir niedergemacht
die iranische afghanische grenze irans
führung fürchtet unmut in der eigenen
bevölkerung sollten noch mehr
flüchtlinge kommen um das eigene volk zu
beruhigen dürfen einige fernsehteams im
transit zentrum an der grenze drehen
dort sitzen hunderte afghanen die
angeblich freiwillig iran wieder
richtung heimat verlassen wollen
meine eltern haben mir gesagt dass die
lage im land seit dem einmarsch der
taliban ruhig ist das leben habe sich
normalisiert und ich könnte wieder nach
hause kommen
irans führung drängt die taliban sich zu
mäßigen und einer einheitsregierung zu
bilden um den flüchtlingsstrom zu
stoppen und die europäer wären wohl
bereit die runs ungeliebten präsidenten
oder sie geld dafür zu zahlen dass er
die afghanischen flüchtlinge im land
hält und nicht abgibt oder durch neueste
richtung westen denn dorthin wollen
zunahm und ihre afghanischen volk die
hier in teheran gestrandet sind sie
suchen hilfe um iran richtung europa zu
verlassen nicht weil es ihr wunsch ist
sondern bittere notwendigkeit
schon mein vater gehörte zu einer
flüchtlings generation was er
hinterlassen hat waren leid krieg und
flucht wenn es das ist was ich meiner
tochter mal hinterlassen werde wofür
habe ich dann gelebt
leid und flucht bestimmen ihr leben auch
hier in iran in einem land das sie
eigentlich nicht will und das doch
zurzeit ihr einziger zufluchtsort ist
über die mutigen frauen in afghanistan
die sich den taliban immer noch
entgegenstellen spricht man guckte mir
später im heute-journal update mit sor
israeli model und aktivistin die selbst
damals mit 13 jahren aus afghanistan
fliehen musste aber erst mal noch mal
weitere nachrichten im überblick 1 wie
geht es weiter mit der inflation zu
diesem gerade viel diskutierten thema
hat sich heute auch die chefin der
europäischen zentralbank christine
lagarde geäußert weil er der halle was
erwartet sie wie sich die inflation
entwickelt etwas mehr inflation als noch
vor ein paar wochen und das ist ja auch
angesichts sehr gut laufenden konjunktur
in europa keine große überraschung mit
der erholung steigen eben in der regel
auch die preise nun geht's schneller als
gedacht war die ezb im sommer für dieses
jahr noch von einem wachstum für die
eurozone von 4,6 prozent ausgegangen
rechnet sie nun mit 5 prozent bei der
inflation korrigierte sie ihre prognose
von 1,9 auf 2,2 prozent herauf die ezb
reagiert darauf indem sie ihr corona
notfallprogramm ein wenig zurück wert
sie will ihre anleihenkäufe reduzieren
zuletzt steckte die zentralbank
monatlich etwa 80 milliarden euro in
diese wertpapiere
unterstützung für unternehmen und
staaten die sich so zu günstigeren
bedingungen finanzieren können ezb
chefin lagarde war ich damit nur ein
kleines stück von ihrem kurs ab die
zinsen bleiben auf rekordtief
geschäftsbanken müssen weiter
strafzinsen zahlen wenn sie geld bei der
zentralbank parken
kritiker werfen der ezb vor mit dem
vielen billigen geld die inflation
anzuheizen sie in schach zu halten das
ist die kernaufgabe der zentralbank da
hat sie sich aber vor kurzem größeren
spielraum verschafft etwas mehr oder
weniger als zwei prozent inflation
nehmen die währungshüter eine zeitlang
in kauf auch bei der aktuell höheren
inflation gehen sie davon aus dass diese
nur vorübergehend ist eine meinung die
nicht alle ökonomen teilen valerie
haller vielen dank
der europäische gerichtshof hat sich in
einem urteil mit der frage beschäftigt
welche konkreten angaben in
kreditverträgen stehen müssen demnach
gehören dazu etwa genaue prozentsätze
bei verzugszinsen anders für die
entscheidung waren rechtsstreitigkeiten
vor einem deutschen gericht zu auto
kreditverträgen und noch ein urteil und
zwar vom bundesgerichtshof zur pflicht
von influenza rinnen und influencer
beiträge als werbung zu kennzeichnen
nach der entscheidung ist allein das
zeigen eines produkts nicht automatisch
schleichwerbung für das gericht kommt es
auf die jeweiligen umstände an etwa ob
es eine gegenleistung gibt oder wie
werblich ein beitrag ist
fünf jahre lang hat sich der deutsche
astronaut matthias maurer auf seine
reise zur iss vorbereitet und in sieben
wochen soll es losgehen besonders
anstrengend sei das training unter
wasser im schweren raumanzug gewesen
erklärte maurer auf einer
pressekonferenz am 31 oktober startet
der 51 jährige saarländer von den usa
aus zur iss
er wird ein halbes jahr auf der
internationalen raumstation bleiben
so und jetzt in diesem heute journal
kommt das was meine kollegin sabine
schulz mit leuchtenden augen als eine
zwiebel ankündigt dabei ist sabine keine
gastro kritikerin sie hat ein auge auf
besondere kinofilme der heute kommt
daher als thriller inspiriert vom fall
amanda knox die selbst darüber
allerdings ziemlich entsetzt war aber
dann tut sich eine ebene nach der
anderen auf welten prallen aufeinander
und geben neue blickwinkel frei
zerrissenheit und zuneigung
verletzlichkeit und härte da hat einer
sein zementiert das bild im kopf
erkennt dass er damit nicht weiterkommt
bill baker ist das was die amerikaner
einen radweg nennen ein ölbohrer
arbeiter aus der erzkonservativen trump
hochburg oklahoma seine heimatstadt
stillwater verlässt er nur ungern
[Musik]
nach europa nach marseille spiel nur aus
einem grund ich besuche meine tochter
sind sie der vater der jungen frau der
amerikanischen studentin
yamana lassen wollte hier studieren und
da hat sich dieses mädchen kennengelernt
lena eines abends fand elena tod und
riecht die polizei die haben sich nur
dafür interessiert das alles nicht eine
araberin schläft
ja das weiß ich glaube ich hätte sie
getötet
der film ist lose inspiriert vom fall
amanda knox der amerikanischen studentin
die 2007 in italien des mordes an ihrer
mitbewohnerin angeklagt wurde doch das
ist hier nur der ausgangspunkt für eine
ganz andere geschichte stillwater ist
vor allem ein film über amerikanische
identität
es geht darum wie wir amerikaner und
sehen und wie wir von der welt gesehen
werden
auch wenn bill seit jahren kaum noch
kontakt zu seiner tochter hatte will er
nun ihre unschuld beweisen um jeden
preis auf eigene faust in einem fremden
land dessen kultur und sprache er nicht
versteht
unterstützung kommt von genie
zufallsbekanntschaft und
alleinerziehende mutter der kleinen
meyer
doch die weltanschauung der zwei ist
mitunter recht unterschiedlich ich will
dass meine tochter freigelassen wird der
rest ist mir scheißegal jetzt bringen
sie hier ein amerikaner
der amerikanische held im gros der alles
tut für seine familie für sich sich
sicher sein vor für sein land auch im
kino hat das immer sehr einseitig
mein film eröffnet einen neuen
blickwinkel und das verstaubt die
konsequenzen dieser
ideologie
dabei spielt mit kathi mit den
stereotypen eines gespaltenen amerikas
und mit unseren vorurteilen ich gebe
nicht auf will dieser wortkarge gläubige
provinz amerikaner überzeugter
waffenbesitzer und doch so fürsorglich
oder will er wieder gut machen als er
bei der eigenen tochter versäumt hat es
ist ein film voller subtiler
zwischentöne und überraschende wendungen
es ist gefährlich wie sie glauben sie
mir packend und doch so viel mehr als
ein thriller ein starker ein
nachdenklicher film mit einem
faszinierenden antihelden mit dem in
absolut oscar würdig
das hat dann hast du mit
als vater als raf- lag als amerikaner in
marseille
der film fordert auch uns die zuschauer
ab heute im kino
regisseur tom mccarthy sagt vielleicht
haben wir zu viel zeit verbracht darauf
zu schauen was uns trennt anstatt zu
sehen was uns vielleicht doch noch
verbindet und mit dieser persönlichen
einsicht empfehle ich ihnen die
spannende runde bei maybrit illner jetzt
gleich die sich wundert wieso corona im
wahlkampf mittlerweile eine
vergleichsweise kleine rolle spielt und
um 0.35 gibt es dann unser heute schnell
update mit nacktem er in allen von uns
allen einen sehr angenehmen abend
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ein starker sturm
zieht derzeit richtung philippinen hat
die stärke 4 kurz vorher hatte es noch 5
von möglichen fünf stufen also beinahe
die höchste stufe dieser gesamte bereich
hier den sie sehen der pazifik der ist
ein bis zwei grad wärmer als normale und
dieses mehr an energie das feuert quasi
den sturm an der weiter richtung taiwan
ziehen wird und mit stärke 3 dort auf
trifft schauen wir nach europa und da
haben wir es vor allem bei uns mit einer
kaltfront zu tun und die kommt morgen
bei uns an und löst durchaus kräftige
gewitter mit starkregen aus im osten
deutschlands kommt noch warme luft an
und in der nacht wird es schauer und
gewitter geben die gewitter werden
allmählich weniger ansonsten lockert es
im osten und im südosten auf mit
tiefsten temperaturen dort bis 10 grad
und im westen 18 grad mild morgen dann
also die schauer gewitter von westen her
die auf 10 zum nachmittag bilden sich
auch im osten schauer und gewitter die
temperaturen erreichen höchstwerte dort
bis 27 grad ganz im westen sind es 20
grad die kommenden tage es gibt am
samstag noch kräftige schauer und auch
gewitter die zähne allmähliche ab
temperaturen bis 24 grad ja und am
sonntag wird es im norden schauer geben
ansonsten wird es allmählich trockener
und montag vor allem ruhiges wetter mit
viel sonnenschein und damit ein schöner
amt